the checkpoints haven't moved the blast
walls and protective paraphernalia built
by western forces remain in place
now manned by the very people they were
put there to stop
there's no war now but the country
remains on a war footing
taliban special forces crisscross kabul
the islamic state bomb threat is a
constant but life here is relatively
normal
exactly a year ago it was very different
we filmed the chaos of the evacuation of
people who lost in these crowds had
served the british government and
military for two decades
people promised safe passage to the uk
many never made it to the gates of the
processing center at the barron hotel
next to the airport
well it's obviously much quieter than it
was exactly a year ago
this is a
barren gate this is the area that people
were brought in to be processed by the
british military and this was the chaos
outside the scenes here
that uh basically shocked the world it's
still a restricted area
um
they don't really like you filming here
at all and just beyond here you can see
and it's hardly changed in the year
the canal
uh where
a lot of people were killed in a suicide
bomb attack which basically brought this
rather chaotic evacuation to an end
the taliban have been here a year now
they're totally in control but this
still feels like a country that's not
quite sure where it's going in any sort
of sense or form
with the taliban fully in charge
hundreds if not thousands who are
qualified to enter the uk are now
effectively on the run
fearing for their lives
we won't name him but this man served
five years at cambastian for the british
military
he's still waiting for news of a plan to
extract him
he's confused by the delay and he feels
abandoned and overshadowed by another
war
one here is a very long time
just look at her what's the difference
between my blood afghan bloods
and
lucrative blood
the uk they eukaryotic crime give
hundred thousand visa for them
they are work for one month and still
one years an hour ago
why they all do this like foreign with
me
do you feel angry do you feel sad
what do you feel towards britain i don't
always like an explanatory to you sir
she's very my feeling is very bad
my life has now become like a hell
i don't know what should i do where we
can go
composed throughout our interview he
finally broke down when i said sky news
would try to help him and his wife and
two children
we can see if we can get the ball
rolling
and we'll talk and we'll talk to our
guys and they can talk to you everybody
appreciate it just very kind of you
because
i don't know what's happening the next
day the next year the next tomorrow i
don't know
i love my family's too much my children
but now i can't do anything
i don't know what should i do for my
life or my family will be going
why they not help us
money requests as many animals money
doing everything
honestly work work with them
money my hairs my life spent with them
i'm happy but they are soldiers
they are all up
but they don't care about me
one year on people like this interpreter
are hiding in family homes moving every
month unable to work unable to send
their children to school
living in fear and waiting for
instructions that they think may never
actually come
stuart ramsey sky news kabul